i've spoken to her mother lupe about it
lupe has always said that ben is her
true love apparently jennifer lopez's
mother lupe always knew ben affleck was
the one
and as they say mama knows best
on tuesday's the view the panelists were
discussing benefit tying the knot in
vegas and that's when sunny hostin
chimed in with her two cents and even
revealed she spoke to jen's mom lupe
about the sin city nuptials i knew they
would get back together
i knew that they were in love i've
spoken to her mother lupe about it lupe
has always said that ben is her true
love and we all have them and i know
that this is going to last forever and
they're going to live happily ever after
and that's why she took his last name
and she loves him of course lupe is a
long time super fan of the view she's
even popped on the show a time or two i
want to point out a woman who might have
helped you form all of that because
she's sitting here
and when lupe's not in the crowd
cheering jen on she's appearing in fun
segments like this one proving she knows
gin best jennifer's first boyfriend
oh go ahead i didn't get it
you got it
louis
louis
yes yes
sure a guy named lewis was jen's first
boyfriend but we're gonna stick with ben
being jen's first love turned husband
[Music]
18 was on the ground where jen and ben
made their love official getting married
in sin city's little white wedding
chapel
and this
was my
wedding
changing area
i am in the tiny bathroom where ben
affleck changed to get married to
jennifer lopez he threw his stuff down
on the sink i'm pretty sure this is
ben's hanger still hanging here from
saturday night but this is what they
wanted a low-key intimate wedding and
the intimate affair included the
couple's nearest and dearest at the
nuptials who watched as jyn walked down
the aisle in a stunning zuhair murad
gown
i am walking down the exact same aisle
that jennifer lopez took her steps
towards ben affleck on saturday night
just after midnight
and now that jen's a married woman her
closest collaborators couldn't be more
excited jay balvin who performed with
jyn during her super bowl halftime show
in 2020 is sending her a whole lot of
love she knows i love her she knows i
have a lot of respect for her so i just
wish her the best and her hustler's
co-star kiki palmer tells e.t jen
deserves this i'm so happy jacob nobody
deserves happiness more you know i think
she works really hard uh she's dedicated
her life to the industry
she's a woman in power you know it's not
easy for us so i'm just happy for her
we're also sending our congrats to mr
and mrs affleck and here's to a lifetime
of love it's just a dream come true
[Music]
you